Le Vente de l'Homme
Nous sommes devant un psaume qui fait face à la réalité de la vie de tous les êtres humains qui sont pieux,
qui contemplent notre vie vécue dans ces mondes de chute depuis la première rébellion de l'humanité contre Dieu,
une vie qui sera toujours caractérisée plus par les afflictions, les difficultés,
pour préserver bien sûr nos cœurs dans l'attente de la Jérusalem céleste,
mais pour nous rappeler que l'encre de notre joie, de notre foi, elle est sûre et certaine,
et nous pouvons toujours puiser suffisamment des puissances et des forces de cette encre qui est Christ,
Christ ressuscité, Christ sur son trône de gloire, Christ le premier-né de la résurrection,
qui nous assure qu'il est en train de nous amener à sa gloire et qu'avec lui et en lui nous sommes héritiers de toutes les choses,
mais surtout Christ qui est en soi-même l'objet suprême d'adoration et de notre joie.
Et donc si nous avons comme encre de notre âme le Seigneur Jésus,
nous pouvons faire face aux difficultés de la vie sans utiliser ces difficultés comme une excuse pour nous plaindre contre Dieu,
pour suggérer n'importe quel moindre type de victimisation.
On n'est jamais cherchant à justifier les moments où on a perdu le courage, où on a été fatigué,
pour justifier l'inconstance de notre vie chrétienne, de notre intégrité, de notre piété.
Donc David a été un grand modèle de cette réalité, il était surtout en type du Christ.
Et la grande leçon de ces psaumes, de cette école des prières qui sont les psaumes, et ces psaumes particulièrement,
c'est que c'est par la prière que nous allons surtout avoir les plus grandes batailles
qui puissent assurer un bon témoignage des vies dans cette vie,
et surtout lorsqu'on traverse les pires circonstances.
On a évoqué la question que possiblement David a souffert beaucoup plus que nous tous ici dans cette salle,
et certainement Christ l'a souffert en finant plus que nous tous dans cette salle.
Et en même temps, David, il a trouvé par les prières, et par des prières bibliques,
la force nécessaire pour endurer ce qu'il a dû endurer avec une vie d'intégrité.
Et donc nous cherchons par ces psaumes la clé que David a trouvée
pour que nous puissions nous conduire aussi avec un si beau témoignage.
Il a été appelé un homme selon le cœur de Dieu, et nous comprenons que nous devons prier
selon le cœur de Dieu, car David manifeste par ses prières qu'il était un homme selon le cœur de Dieu,
car ses prières étaient caractérisées par l'harmonisation de ses désirs au désir de Dieu,
pour lui et pour sa vie, et à travers sa vie.
C'est-à-dire, la grande vérité pour nous, c'est que Dieu, si nous appartenons à lui,
si nous sommes son peuple élu, Dieu sera glorifié dans nos vies.
Nos histoires sont sous la gouvernance de Dieu, et l'objectif de Dieu,
c'est de ressortir comme les personnages principaux de notre vie,
pour notre bien, et par une question de justice.
Donc Dieu n'est pas un Dieu capricieux qui a besoin de nos louanges.
Et le fait qu'il soit déterminé à être glorifié dans nos vies,
ce n'est pas une espèce de relation utilitaire avec nos vies pour ressortir comme les dieux glorieux.
La préservation de sa place en tant que seul mériteur d'adoration,
c'est la protection aussi de la source de notre joie.
Si Dieu n'était pas toujours en train de nous rappeler que notre joie n'est qu'étrouvée en lui seul,
on serait toujours en train de retomber dans des démarches idolâtres dans nos vies.
Si nous pensons aujourd'hui que si cette bénédiction arrive dans ma vie,
je serais dans la joie, c'est un mensonge,
car aucune bénédiction qui puisse arriver dans nos vies
n'aurait la capacité de satisfaire nos âmes,
comme Dieu seul a la capacité de les faire.
Et donc, lorsqu'il veut préserver cette place en tant que Dieu suprême,
seul digne d'adoration,
c'est car il sait qu'il nous a créés pour trouver notre satisfaction
dans les seuls objets suprêmes qui peuvent satisfaire les démons de notre âme.
Et c'est Dieu lui-même.
Et donc, il gouverne nos histoires de manière à préserver nos cœurs
centrés sur les seuls endroits, les seuls objets,
ou la seule personne qui est capable de satisfaire pleinement nos demandes dans notre vie.
Et de cette manière, Dieu gouverne notre histoire
en conduisant notre histoire à constater et à contempler
qu'il est notre seul bien et qu'il est notre bien suprême.
Et même les bonnes choses que nous pouvons trouver par la grâce de Dieu
qui l'ajoute à nos vies ne peuvent pas être réjouies correctement
si elles ne sont pas préservées comme des choses qui vont agrandir notre joie en Dieu
et jamais substituer Dieu dans nos vies.
C'est comme cette illustration de Dion Piper,
si un mari donne une fleur à son épouse,
l'épouse ne peut pas tomber plus amoureuse de la rose
qui est de son époux.
Et toutes les bonnes choses que nous attendons recevoir de la part de Dieu
n'auraient jamais la possibilité de nous provoquer la même joie
que Dieu peut produire.
Et donc David l'avait compris,
que même s'il traverse les difficultés dans sa vie,
toute sa vie était une opportunité pour que Dieu soit glorifié dans son histoire,
pour que Dieu ressort comme les grands héros de sa vie
et dans sa vie pour lui et à travers sa vie pour les autres,
Dieu serait connu comme le seul digne d'être cherché, d'être adoré.
Ok ?
Donc la première partie de cette grande vérité,
de ces psaumes,
c'est que pour les siens,
Dieu est déterminé à conduire nos vies à sa gloire,
à glorifier son histoire.
Donc mon histoire, je ne sais pas comment,
quand je regarde ma vie aujourd'hui,
je ne sais pas comment,
Dieu peut transformer ces circonstances difficiles
dans sa gloire.
Mais Dieu, il essaie et il le fera et c'est inévitable.
Et donc,
ayant cette consolation,
les descriptives ou la description
ou l'explication
de nos vies,
c'est Dieu sera glorifié dans mon histoire,
autant mieux
pour nous tous,
de chercher intentionnellement
à marcher dans la direction
de la gloire des dieux dans nos vies.
Et donc, au lieu de se dire, David,
Dieu,
tu m'as dit que tu m'allais bénir,
que je suis ton enfant,
mais ma vie,
elle ne semble pas comme la vie d'un enfant
des dieux.
Si je suis l'enfant d'un Dieu si puissant,
pourquoi ma vie n'est pas meilleure aujourd'hui ?
Vous comprenez ?
Ça aurait pu être
la dynamique de David.
Si mes circonstances étaient meilleures,
je serais en train de prier
comme cette personne-là
a la capacité de prier à l'Assemblée.
Ou je serais plus en train de faire l'évangélisation.
Ou je me protégerais plus
contre ces péchés.
Car c'est le manque de la personne
pour mon mariage
qui rend inévitable pour moi
de tomber
dans ces péchés.
Et ce n'est pas du tout
de cette manière
que David raisonnait.
Il regardait
les difficultés
pas comme une excuse
pour s'affaiblir,
mais pour être davantage
résolu dans l'endurance
à manifester
que Dieu peut être glorifié
par la délivrance
de ses difficultés,
par la bénédiction
dans cette terre dans ma vie,
mais il peut être davantage glorifié
aussi pour démontrer
qu'il est digne de ma persévérance.
Qu'il a en soi
la capacité
de pourvoir
une joie
d'une nature
qui surmonte
même les privations
que je suis en train de traverser.
Dieu me suffit
et Dieu
est plus glorifié
dans ma capacité
d'endurer
les souffrances
en intégrité
et en fidélité
et donc
l'histoire
sera
beaucoup plus belle
lorsqu'il va
honorer
ma persévérance,
ma patience
par sa grâce
et que les personnes
vont contempler
l'intégrité
que j'ai pu vivre
par la provision
de Dieu
jusqu'à ce que Dieu
décide d'apporter
la délivrance.
Et donc David
dans ses psaumes
il nous enseigne
que comme Dieu
sera glorifié
dans nos vies
nous devons chercher
intentionnellement
et de manière résolue
et déterminée
à rendre gloire
à Dieu
dans nos vies
à honorer Dieu
peu importe
quelles soient
les circonstances.
Et donc nous sommes
en train de considérer
ces psaumes
en cherchant
des pistes
ou des leçons
par rapport à
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire
de devant les pires circonstances
prier
selon le cœur
de Dieu.
Ok ?
Afin de préserver
un témoignage
d'intégrité
en attendant
la bénédiction
des dieux
nous devons prier
comme David
prie dans ces psaumes.
Et donc
nous avons déjà couvert
la première grande moitié
du texte
je vous cite
juste les versets
et les premières
leçons
qu'on a prises
donc pour préserver
une vie
selon le cœur
de Dieu
face aux pires
difficultés
nous devons prier
avec un cœur
fixé à l'éternel
comme fondement
constant et certain
de notre espérance.
Donc c'est les versets
premiers
ou les versets 2
où David
il va dire
j'avais mis
en l'éternel
mon espérance
et il s'est incliné
vers moi
et il a écouté
mes cris.
Donc c'était la résolution
la détermination
d'attendre
la solution
pourvue
par Dieu seul
et pas prendre
des raccourcis
il était patient
et persévérant
dans son attente
et l'éternel
est venu vers lui.
Donc fixé
en cœur
fixé à l'éternel
comme fondement
constant et certain
de notre espérance.
Donc on a compris
dans chacun
ou chacune
de ces leçons
comment Christ
est l'accomplissement
parfait
et ces psaumes.
Et donc c'est notamment
cette patience
que l'humanité
a dû attendre
jusqu'à la venue
du Christ
et quand Christ vient
c'est donc
l'immanence
de Dieu transcendant
et donc Christ
il devient pour nous
la manifestation
suprême
de la manière
dont Dieu
nous a sauvés
nous a délivrés
et donc si Dieu
nous a montré
qu'il a pourvu
cette solution
suprême
à la croix
c'est clair
que pour toutes
les difficultés
de nos vies
nous devons être sûrs
que nous pouvons
attendre en intégrité
que Dieu
va manifester
ses sons.
Ok ?
Le deuxième point
qu'on a vu ensemble
c'est que
c'est un cœur
qui aspire
des nouvelles
manifestations
de la puissante
miséricorde
de la grâce
de Dieu
et de la grâce
de Dieu.
Donc verset 2
ou 3
selon les versions
il m'a retiré
de la force
de la destruction
du fond
de la boue
et il a dressé
mes pieds
sur les rocs
il a affermi
mes pas
et donc ici
David
il est entrant
de se souvenir
des moments
dans sa vie
où les choses
étaient très difficiles
il a traversé
vraiment des situations
il était au bord
de la mort
il ne pouvait pas
s'en sortir
et donc Dieu
l'a délivré
d'une manière
incroyable
et la solution
des dieux
elle est toujours
une solution
miséricordieuse
dans le sens
où Dieu
va nous retrouver
dans nos misères
et ensuite
il va nous placer
par ces solutions
dans un schéma
solide
et affermi
et on a parlé
de cette difficulté
qui quand on essaye
de trouver la solution
par nous-mêmes
souvent on finit
par marcher
dans un terrain
tortueux
et piégeux
ce sont des raccourcis
qui ne veulent jamais
les coups
car plus tard
ça va prolonger
davantage
ce qu'on attendait
en termes
de marcher
sur un chemin
certain
sûr et épais
et donc bien sûr
avant tout
c'est la manière
dont Christ
nous a quittés
de l'enfer
et nous a placés
déjà dans la gloire
et qu'il a laissés
pour nous
un chemin
dans ce pèlerinage
qui est un chemin
ferme d'intégrité
la troisième manière
qu'on doit prier
c'est avec un cœur
qui a pour joie
la louange salvatrice
des dieux
donc soit
en regardant
en arrière
et nous rappelant
des manières
dont Dieu
nous a délivrés
soit en anticipant
les prochaines
délivrances
des dieux
mais d'avoir
véritablement
comme l'objectif
suprême
de nos vies
de désirer
que ce soit clair
pour nous
et pour tous
que c'est Dieu
qui a trouvé la solution
pour que tous
voient combien
dignes d'adoration
est Dieu
et pas pour que les personnes
se disent
ou nous disent
quelle manière intelligente
ou magistrale
dont cette personne
s'est en sortie
de cette situation
non
on veut vraiment
que tous voient clairement
que c'est Dieu
qui a pourvu
ses saluts
car c'est Dieu
qui est la seule source
de joie
pour nous
donc David va dire ça
au verset 3 et 4
il a mis dans ma bouche
un quantique nouveau
ce qui n'a pas lieu
quand c'est
nous qui avons
plutôt l'impression
qu'on a trouvé la solution
on va mettre dans la bouche
un quantique nouveau
par rapport à nous-mêmes
et c'est nous-mêmes
qui mettons ces champs
dans notre bouche
ou
on va louer
les personnes
qui nous ont délivré
de ces circonstances
donc il dit
et qui ne se tournent pas
vers les otans
ou les menteurs
et donc
des solutions
pas intègres
et on va
faire des éloges
constants
à des personnes
donc à l'opposé
par exemple
de l'exemple
de Jean-Baptiste
qui a pu
confronter
même Hérode
dans sa situation
et donc des fois
les chrétiens
pensent qu'ils ne peuvent
pas oser
à critiquer
ou à s'opposer
à la manière
immorale
de certaines personnes
qui dans leur vie
semblent être important
et qui semblent avoir
les contrôles
ou l'autorité
sur leurs biens
donc on essaye
de plaire
les otans
et les menteurs
pour voir
s'ils peuvent trouver
une faveur pour nous
au lieu de faire confiance
à Dieu
et voir que Dieu seul
est la source
de notre joie
quatrième manière
dont on doit prier
et donc dans ce sens là
Christ
il est la source
inépuisable
d'adoration
quelqu'un
qui a toujours
la capacité
des pourvoir
des motivations
fraîches
par la manière
dont il nous a sauvés
donc quatrième manière
dont on doit prier
c'est rempli
des reconnaissances
pour l'historique
des bienfaits
des dieux
dans les versets 5
David
il va
évoquer
ou il va
mentionner
toutes les merveilles
et les descendants
des dieux
donc là
c'est de nous concentrer
sur le fait
que Dieu
est déjà en train
de manifester
il a déjà manifesté
un nombre
incontable
des bénédictions
envers nos vies
mais en plus de ça
par les bienfaits
des dieux
envers nous
les merveilles
des dieux
envers nous
nous voyons aussi
que Dieu
a toujours
un dessein
pour nos vies
on ne sait pas
toujours
comment les choses
aujourd'hui
vont se connecter
pour notre bien
pour sa gloire
mais nous devons être sûrs
toujours que Dieu
a un dessein
pour nos vies
et aucune chose
n'est en train
de surprendre Dieu
pour ce qui se passe
dans nos vies
aujourd'hui
donc même
l'essor est tiré
sur les panneaux
de la robe
mais c'est du Seigneur
qui procède
toute décision
donc même
quand on jette des dés
ils sont en train
d'accomplir
la volonté des dieux
lorsque les résultats
ils sortent
donc notre Dieu
n'est pas un dieu
qui a livré
les coursus
de l'histoire
tout simplement
à l'agence libre
des agents libres
qui sont là
en train d'agir
ou même pas
avec l'idée
des choses
qui peuvent être
hasardeuses
ou aléatoires
donc c'est un dieu
qui a un dessein
et qui est en train
de conduire
toutes les choses
à notre dessein
même les mal
qui sont faits
contre nous
même les injustices
qui sont pratiquées
et qui Dieu les permet
sont en train
de contribuer
à notre bien
et la manifestation
suprême
de tout ça
c'est Christ lui-même
qui est de manière
très surprenante
lorsque les êtres humains
étaient en train
de mettre
Christ à mort
ils étaient en train
d'accomplir
les desseins
de Dieu
pour la rédemption
de toute l'humanité
et donc nous pouvons
être sûrs
que toutes les choses
concourent
à notre bien
selon les desseins
de Dieu
on a considéré
aussi
que nous devons prier
cinquième
point
avec un cœur
dont la volonté
souveraine
est de satisfaire
la volonté
de Dieu
et donc
si Dieu
en descend
et s'il a décidé
que je traverserai
des moments
difficiles
dans ma vie
Dieu
il attend
que je sois
obéissant
aujourd'hui
quand tout va bien
et que je sois
encore obéissant
quand tout semble
aller mal
surtout rassuré
par un dessein
parfait
cette endurance
qui l'attendait moi
et donc
nous pouvons
être parfois
conscients
nous devons être
toujours conscients
que tous les problèmes
qu'on traverse
sont liés
à la rébellion
de l'humanité
contre Dieu
les péchés
originales d'Adam
mais parfois
des difficultés
qu'on traverse
elles sont liées
à des péchés
spécifiques
qu'on pratique
dans nos vies
et l'une des choses
les plus difficiles
qu'on traverse
quand on est
dans des moments
très difficiles
c'est la sensation
que
les circonstances
qu'on est en train
de vivre
c'est Dieu
qui est en train
de pourger
des péchés
dans nos vies
il est en train
de nous corriger
comme à des enfants
nous sommes sous
les châtiments
des dieux
c'est plus facile
de traverser
la difficulté
comme David
dans la première partie
de sa vie
lorsqu'il était
en pleine intégrité
car il était
donc il n'était pas
parfait
mais il était
pieux
intègre
et il a résisté
à des nombreuses
opportunités
de saisir
des opportunités
des raccourcis
qui n'étaient pas
selon la volonté
des dieux
donc lorsque
Saül est persécuté
de manière injuste
il a eu des occasions
où il a pu
attraper
Saül
où Saül a été
tellement vulnérable
devant lui
mais lui
il a persévéré
en intégrité
en attendant
la délivrance
de Dieu
donc la paix
qu'on expérimente
quand on est
devant une souffrance
et qu'on est
plutôt rassuré
que cette souffrance
n'est pas
la correction
d'un péché
qu'on est en train
de préserver
ou de prolonger
dans nos vies
c'est une paix
qu'on ne peut pas
acheter par l'argent
c'est une paix
incroyable
et ça nous motive
davantage
à traverser la souffrance
en paix
mais David
il savait aussi
que même s'il avait péché
le plus important
pour lui
c'était d'être justifié
et donc
ça parle aussi
de la manière
dont on s'est répentis
l'authenticité
de notre répentance
si nous sommes
authentiquement répentis
ça veut dire
que nous sommes résolus
à ne pas rester
dans la pratique
du péché
et donc David
il a dit
tu ne veux pas
offrandre
le sacrifice
car tu m'as percé
des oreilles
c'est-à-dire
tu as mis dans mon cœur
ta loi
donc ce qu'il avait
en train de dire
Seigneur
tout semble aller très mal
et j'ai besoin
que tu me délivres
et ce qu'il est en train
de dire dans ses versets
c'est comme si
il était en train de dire
Dieu délivre-moi vite
car pour moi
chercher une sortie
qui ne t'honore pas
n'existe même pas
pour moi
je veux faire
ta volonté
si ta volonté
va inclure la souffrance
pour moi aujourd'hui
j'embrasse la souffrance
car je suis déterminé
à obéir ta volonté
et donc on a fait
une espèce d'immersion
dans l'hébreu
car les dimanches derniers
c'était les dimanches
de la Pentecôte
et nous avons compris
que ces passages
nous parlent
du Christ
comme celui
qui accomplit parfaitement
l'obéissance
qu'on n'arrive pas à accomplir
que Christ
il est celui
qui donc
par son obéissance
parfaite
il pourvoit
non seulement
cette déclaration
de la part de Dieu
qui nous dit
nous sommes justifiés
c'est-à-dire
la justice du Christ
maintenant est la nôtre
et là on est
pleinement acquittés
mais ça parle aussi
de la Pentecôte
comme
l'accomplissement
de cette provision
de justice
qui substitue
notre manque de justice
elle produit
elle rend possible
aussi notre régénération
et donc
une capacité nouvelle
radicale
de préserver
de persévérer
en obéissance
de progresser
de marcher
en santé
les ministères
principales
du Saint-Esprit
chez les chrétiens
c'est de nous conduire
et préserver
notre santé
et de nous conduire
la progression
en santé
et donc
notre prière
quand on se voit
devant la souffrance
c'est légitime
de demander à Dieu
Dieu
délivre-moi
vient vite
et hâte
à me délivrer
mais nous devons prier
comme Jésus
toutefois
que ta volonté
soit faite
et l'on la mienne
et si c'est pour
que tu sois glorifié
par mon endurance
qu'il soit ainsi
je persévère
avec l'aide
du Saint-Esprit
je persévère
en intégrité
à travers ça
et donc
un cœur
qui sera capable
de préserver
un bon témoignage
parmi la souffrance
c'est un cœur
qui ne voit pas
la souffrance
par la perspective
de la victimisation
et par la perspective
d'une nouvelle opportunité
de glorifier Dieu
davantage
et d'être déterminé
à obéir
surtout
dans cette période
de difficulté
ok
ensuite
c'est un cœur
aussi déterminé
à proclamer publiquement
la bonne nouvelle
du salut
donc Jésus
il a accompli
par son obéissance
parfaite
et il a accompli
notamment
en vénant
avec les rouleaux
du livre écrit
donc on sait très bien
que Christ va
inaugurer
ou rendre son ministère
explicitement
inauguré
de manière publique
lorsqu'il rentre
dans cette synagogue
il prend les rouleaux
de livres
il prend Esaïe
et donc là
il prend les rouleaux
de livres écrits
à son sujet
on voit de manière
magistrale
comment
Cepsum
il anticipait déjà
de manière très littérale
cet accomplissement
du Christ
qui vient surtout
pour prononcer
et proclamer
la bonne nouvelle
et Christ est venu
proclamer la bonne nouvelle
parmi les pires
des souffrances
qu'il a dû vivre
la plus grande
de toutes les nouvelles
c'est cette capacité
du Christ
d'endurer la souffrance
pour nous
et pour voir par là
la satisfaction
des demandes
de la justice
des dieux
à cet égard
et donc nous
n'aurons jamais
des excuses
les plus on souffre
les plus on est apte
à proclamer
la bonne nouvelle
comme les Christ
c'est une bonne nouvelle
celle qui a la capacité
de préserver
des personnes
qui souffrent
mais qui ne souffrent pas
en vivant la souffrance
caractérisée
par les manques
de joie
caractérisée
par un visage
attristé
les fruits de l'esprit
c'est la joie
c'est l'un des premiers
fruits
l'esprit
si le Saint-Esprit
habite en nous
il nous a déjà décroché
des attentes
éphémères
de ce monde
il nous a déjà mis
l'encre
de notre âme
pour anticiper
notre joie
dans l'espérance
et il nous permet
il nous rend capable
comme il a rendu capable
à Paul et Pierre
de chanter
des louanges
des joies
même dans la prison
même après avoir été battu
et frappé
et donc
ce qui deviendra
un témoignage puissant
d'évangélisation
envers ceux
qui nous entourent
parfois
c'est notamment
la manière
dont on traverse
la souffrance
avec des chants
des louanges
dans notre bouche
avec la bonne nouvelle
annoncée en tout temps
et donc
les Christ
nous montrent
et David aussi
il était sûr
pour lui
Seigneur
si tu mets des livres
c'est pas pour que
je sors
en racontant
combien je suis
un enfant
tellement préféré
par Dieu
car des fois
c'est comme ça
qu'on entend
les témoignages
j'étais dans la pauvreté
et aujourd'hui
j'ouvre mon frigo
il y a du camembert
etc
j'ai déjà entendu
un témoignage
un peu comme ça
et là en fait
ce qu'on doit se demander
comme dit
mon père
c'est qui a plus
la capacité
de nous convaincre
de la capacité
de Dieu
de pouvoir
la satisfaction
la consolation
les touts
c'est celui
qui aujourd'hui
a un laptop
d'appel
ou c'est celui
qui a perdu
un enfant
et qui peut quand même
continuer de chanter
les louanges des dieux
comme
il is where with my soul
tout va bien
avec mon âme
ces chants glorieux
et cet homme
qui avait perdu
toute sa famille
dans un naufrage
son épouse
son de ses enfants
et qui a pu dire
tout va bien
avec mon âme
donc quand on voit
cet évangile
il a la capacité
de faire face
même aux pires
tragédies de la vie
et la bonne nouvelle
de l'évangile
c'est la bonne nouvelle
qui doit être
proclamée
sur l'arrière-plan
notamment
de notre enfer
et l'enfer
qu'on devrait vivre
est infiniment pire
de toutes les circonstances
difficiles
qu'on traverse
dans cette vie
et donc
il va bien
que ces messages
soient portés parfois
pour qu'ils puissent
éclater et luire
comme une bonne nouvelle
même
parmi les ténèbres
ok
et donc là
on doit être déterminé
à proclamer publiquement
la bonne nouvelle
du salut
et donc pour nous approcher
des points
qui nous restent
nous allons donc
considérer
une nouvelle manière
dont nous devons prier
donc nous devons prier
avec un cœur
qui se fie davantage
à la miséricorde
des dieux
qu'à sa propre innocence
et donc là
nous allons lire
les versets 11
toi éternel
tu ne me refuseras pas
tes compassions
ta bonté
et ta fidélité
me garderont
toujours
car des mots
son ombre
m'environnent
les châtiments
de mes iniquités
m'atteignent
et je ne plus
en supporter
la vue
ils sont plus nombreux
que les cheveux
de ma tête
et mon courage
m'abandonne
veuille me délivrer
au éternel
éternel
vient en hâte
à mon secours
donc ici
c'est quelque chose
qui va bien
avec toutes les circonstances
de nos vies
malheureusement
quand on est en train
d'éduquer nos enfants
et c'est plus facile
de donner des exemples
de nos enfants
pour faire un peu
comme les paraboles
car on sait très bien
qu'ils ont une capacité
de représenter
des manières plus authentiques
et évidentes
des choses
qu'on essaye de cacher
avec un peu plus d'artifice
et la réalité
c'est que des fois
quand on essaye
de corriger nos enfants
on essaye
de les encourager
à apprendre
les plus tôt que possible
que nous
en tant que pécheurs
la sortie
la plus vite
la plus correcte
de tous les péchés
qu'on commet
ça commence
par la reconnaissance
de nos péchés
et de notre nature pécheresse
comme les enfants
on a plutôt
la première action
c'est de chercher
à nous excuser
ou de culpabiliser
l'autre
ou les circonstances
et David ici
c'est clair
qu'il était
conscient
des moments
où il a commis
des péchés
vraiment très graves
et il est préservé
dans la Bible
comme un homme
selon le cœur de Dieu
non seulement
par rapport
à la manière
dont il a vécu
une vie d'intégrité
et des piétés
incroyables
bien au-dessus
de la moyenne
mais surtout
par rapport
à l'authenticité
de son cœur
lorsqu'il péchait
on voyait
que David
ne se voyait jamais
même lorsqu'il était
dans des moments
des positions
de grande importance
il ne se voyait jamais
comme quelqu'un
qui était important
sur la base
de ses propres mérites
il savait
qu'il a été
choisi par Dieu
pour occuper
une position
et que Dieu lui-même
était la source
de sa piété
et quand on lit
les psaumes
quand les psaumes
nous parlent
des méchants
et des justes
on sait très bien
que les justes
ne sont pas les parfaits
et que les méchants
ne peuvent pas être
tout simplement
n'importe quel méchant
car nous sommes tous méchants
en termes de corruption
de péché
mais les méchants
et les justes
dans les psaumes
c'est de manifester
cette méchanceté
explicite à l'extrême
qui va toujours
avec la notion
d'une espèce
d'hypocrisie religieuse
et de vouloir
accomplir ses buts
dans la vie
par l'imposition
de la force
de la manipulation
et de l'hypocrisie
une opposition
ouverte à Dieu
ou une opposition
à la volonté de Dieu
de manière cachée
en utilisant la religion
ceux qui méprisaient
David en tant qu'ouan
par exemple
et qui parfois
accusaient David
diffamait David
à cause
de leur jalousie
lorsque David
souffrait la persécution
il disait très vite
voilà
il ne peut pas être
loin des dieux
car s'il était
les préférés des dieux
il serait dans
des meilleures conditions
et de l'autre côté
David
il n'était pas parfait
il faisait toujours mention
de la miséricorde des dieux
de la grâce des dieux
mais il était beaucoup
plus sensible
au péché
et donc lorsqu'il
préserve David
comme un homme
selon les coeurs de Dieu
nous devons aller
vers certains psaumes
pour contempler
combien attristé
était David
quand il avait
commis un péché
et il n'était pas
si attristé que ça
par rapport aux conséquences
négatives
de ses transgressions
les châtiments
ou les punitions
qui viendraient
au contraire
il les embrassait
il a dit
il vaut mieux
tomber sous
les châtiments des dieux
qui est d'être livré
aux ennemis
car pour plus
que Dieu soit tout puissant
et qu'il puisse déverser
toute sa puissance
contre moi
on fait confiance
à sa miséricorde
à sa grâce
dans sa correction
mais avant tout
son rapport
avec les péchés
n'était pas
quelles seront
les conséquences
pour moi
c'était surtout
combien j'ai attristé
les coeurs des dieux
ça c'est vraiment
une clé
pour identifier
la distinction
entre un vrai chrétien
et quelqu'un
qui pense être chrétien
mais n'est pas
on doit lui demander
quand il est découvert
dans un péché
quelle est
ta préoccupation
qu'est-ce qui t'accable
à ce moment-là
et parfois
on entend parler
ma réputation
a été terrassée
cette personne
va m'abandonner
je vais perdre
mon emploi
par contre
pour David
c'était
redonne à moi
la joie du salut
n'enlève pas
de moi
l'intimité
de ton esprit
la grande question
c'est
est-ce qu'on a
la sensation
qu'on a attristé
les coeurs du père
ou est-ce qu'on a
par exemple
brisé quelque chose
qui était très cher
et donc David
il est
un homme selon
le coeur de Dieu
car il n'essaie
jamais
de chercher
à justifier
ses péchés
à cause des circonstances
ou de cacher
ses fautes
ou de dire
ok
j'ai mal agi ici
mais regarde
tout ce que j'ai déjà fait
il est conscient
même les moments
où il est en train
de vivre
une vie plutôt pieuse
il dit à Dieu
Dieu pardonne-moi
même des péchés
qui m'y sont cachés
s'il faut
assumer quelque chose
il va assumer
qu'il n'est pas
sans
qu'il n'est pas parfait
et qu'il a besoin
que Dieu soit
constamment
en train de pourger
ses impuretés
purifie-moi
avec l'isope
mais dans ce cas-là
il nous semble
qu'il est vraiment
dans ces moments
de sa vie
où il était conscient
que toutes les choses
qu'il était en train
de souffrir
étaient clairement
des souffrances
dues à un péché
très grave
qu'il avait commis
mais là
il va faire appel
non à son innocence
à la grâce
et à la miséricorde
de Dieu
il va s'effier
davantage à la miséricorde
de Dieu
qu'à sa propre innocence
donc il dit
toi éternel
tu ne me réfuseras pas
tes compassions
ici c'est une transition
envers
entre les passages
intérieure et cellula
c'est intéressant
car il avait dit
malgré ma souffrance
je suis résolu
à proclamer
la bonne nouvelle
et la bonne nouvelle
comme on a vu
a à voir avec
la justice des dieux
bien sûr
mais ce sont
les bonnes nouvelles
dans les passages
il nous dit
les bonnes nouvelles
de tes compassions
de ta fidélité
de ta miséricorde
donc lorsqu'on va
annoncer l'évangile
il faut bien sûr
qu'on annonce
l'évangile
de la condamnation
juste des êtres humains
pour produire la répentance
mais si la manière
dont on prêche
ou on vit l'évangile
est plus caractérisée
par ces légalismes
qui est toujours prêt
à condamner
sur tous les autres
ces évangélisations
qui vont mettre
des pancartes à la roue
en disant
vous êtes un enfer
etc
mais qu'on voit
jamais
ta grâce
est encore plus abondante
abondante
que ton jugement
et ta justice
on n'a pas
communiqué
les vrais évangiles
et on n'est pas
en train de vivre
en harmonie
avec l'évangile
et la réalité
c'est que
comme il est quelqu'un
qui est constamment
en train d'annoncer
les compassions
et la bonté
et la fidélité
des dieux
il peut aussi
anticiper
que Dieu
les traite
de cette même manière
donc toi éternel
tu ne me refuseras
pas tes compassions
je ne suis pas là
en train de prier
pour te montrer
combien belle est ma prière
et combien j'ai bien compris
quelles sont les effaces
que je dois mettre
dans la prière
je suis là
car je suis totalement
dépendant
de tes compassions
et je sais que tu aimes bien
être glorifié
surtout
par tes compassions
des milliers
et des milliers
des générations
Dieu veut être connu
comme les dieux
des compassions
ta bonté
ta fidélité
m'égarderont
pour toujours
donc cette assurance
doit être là
même les moments
où on est en train
de traverser des difficultés
où nous sommes conscients
que nous sommes peut-être
être en train
d'être pourgés
et châtiés
à cause des péchés
qu'on a commis
ou qu'on est en train
encore de commettre
car Satan
il aime bien
nous conduire
jusqu'à cette conclusion
même avec le Saint-Esprit
cette tribulation
c'est une tribulation
que tu es en train
de vivre
à cause
de tes péchés
par contre
à partir d'ici
des
suggestions opposées
lorsque Satan
est en train
de souffler
comment peux-tu
t'es considéré
chrétien
tu es plutôt
un hypocrite
un chrétien
n'allait jamais
être si récidive
dans ce type
de péché
il vaut mieux
abandonner
ces masques
et t'es livrer
complètement
en péché
il n'y a plus
d'espoir
pour toi
sauf que
de l'autre côté
le Saint-Esprit
est en train de dire
oui
cette situation
que tu vis
c'est à cause
de tes péchés
par contre
rappelle-toi
que ça n'a jamais
dépendu
de ta performance
accroche-toi
aux compassions
des dieux
il a été fidèle
pour te délivrer
radicalement
du péché
et il est fidèle
et juste
pour te pardonner
il suffit
que ta répentance
soit sincère
soit biblique
que tu sois résolu
et déterminé
à laisser les péchés
et à progresser
en santé
et donc
la voix
du Saint-Esprit
elle apporte
cette condamnation
cette abomination
envers les péchés
mais elle apporte
aussi toujours
l'espoir
et la puissance
nécessaire
pour surmonter
les péchés
et David fait appel
aussi ici
aux compassions
des dieux
non seulement
par rapport
à cette bataille
affreuse
contre les restes
péchés
chez les chrétiens
mais notamment
à cause
du niveau
des souffrances
qu'il est en train
de traverser
à cause
de ses péchés
donc là
il est en train
de provoquer
c'est la détermination
des dieux
de se présenter
à nous
comme un père
un père
qui renouvelle
ses compassions
envers nos difficultés
à obéir
et un père
qui nous aime
à tel point
qu'il veut purger
nos péchés
et donc
il apporte
des manières
sages
et des manières
chirurgicales
la mesure
exacte
et nécessaire
pour pourger
ses péchés
dans nos vies
et en même temps
en même temps
qu'il est
en train
de nous punir
nous châtier
il est en train
d'expérimenter
des compassions
à cause
des souffrances
qu'on est en train
de souffrir
comprenez
et david
il connaît
très bien
les caractères
paternels
des dieux
il connaît
mon structure
il sait
que je suis
de la poussière
ma difficulté
de me battre
contre ses péchés
en même temps
il m'aime
comme un enfant
donc il ne va pas
être négligé
envers ses péchés
il va pourger
ses péchés
de ma vie
et en même temps
pendant que je souffre
pendant qu'il est en train
de pourger
ses péchés
de ma vie
il est là
comme mon père
qui a des compassions
combien difficile
pour nous
les parents
de trouver
cet équilibre
des fois
très léger
dans nos corrections
et en effet
qui contribuer
à leur perdition
des fois
plus sévère
qu'on est des vrais
lettres
et on perd
le coeur
de nos enfants
car ils n'ont
jamais les ressenti
d'une compassion
paternelle
avec nos souffrances
mais nous
avons un Dieu
qui fait ces choses
de manière parfaite
et David
savait embrasser
cette période
et donc il va dire
des mots
sans nombre
m'environnent
les châtiments
de mes iniquités
m'atteignent
et je ne puis
supporter la vue
ils sont plus nombreux
que les cheveux
de ma tête
et mon courage
m'abandonne
donc la souffrance
de David
pour pourger
ses péchés
est arrivé
jusqu'à ce point
humilié
persécuté
par son propre enfant
il a perdu
l'enfant
qui serait
né
de l'adulterre
qu'il avait commis
maintenant
tous les royaumes
étaient complètement
bouleversés
il était persécuté
à vie
sur les bords
de la mort
et il était conscient
que toutes ces choses
étaient les résultats
de ses péchés
mais c'était
au niveau
des souffrances
telles
qu'il arrive
à ce point
il dit
j'essaye de persévérer
en intégrité
jusqu'ici
mais là
les courage
m'abandonnent
c'est comme si
je suis arrivé
au bout
de mes forces
des forces
pour rester
intègre
en tant que modèle
des piétés
et aussi modèle
des répentances
je ne sais même
plus comment
continuer
même pour prier
maintenant
c'est difficile
c'est comme si
j'avais plus
de force
les courage
m'abandonnent
c'est comme si
j'étais
totalement terrassé
il n'y a même pas
des mots
qui sortent
de ma bouche
et là
il va faire
ses cris
veux m'aider
livré
au éternel
viens en hâte
à mon sécour
même
dans cette
totale dépendance
d'attendre
de prier
de persévérer
lui qui disait
tes merveilles
sur moi
sont plus grandes
que je ne
puisse compter
maintenant
la sensation
c'est que
ses mots
sont plus nombreux
que les cheveux
de sa tête
la sensation
c'est comme si
les mots
étaient plus nombreux
que les bienfaits
des dieux
mais quand on dit
que les bienfaits
des dieux
sont incontables
c'est quelque chose
impossible de faire
mais les cheveux
de la tête
c'est encore possible
et la grâce
des dieux
veut nous rappeler
par ces passages
que même si on était
en train de vivre
cette situation
on pourrait être sûr
que notre Père Céleste
il sait se compatir
avec les souffrances
qu'on est en train
de souffrir
et pourquoi on peut dire ça
car il a prouvé ça
en envoyant Jésus Christ
donc c'est qu'il va
rendre tous les absurds
qui ont pu se traverser
des choses comprensibles
c'est d'avoir
été confronté
en Christ
par un absurde
encore plus grand
un dieu
qui lorsque nous sommes
en train de souffrir
et on se demande
où était dieu
lorsque j'étais en train
de souffrir
la réponse
il était en train
de souffrir
avec nous
car c'est le seul dieu
c'est le seul vrai dieu
bien sûr
mais parmi toutes les religions
qui ont des faux dieux
c'est le seul dieu
qui vient souffrir
avec nous
et ces passages
a des versets
incroyables
qui nous montrent
que le Seigneur Jésus Christ
lorsqu'il a traversé
sa passion
particulièrement
quand on considère
sa souffrance
au Gétsémanie
on va retrouver
ces passages
où il dit
Matthieu 26
verset 36
si vous voulez suivre
là-dessus
Jésus
alla avec eux
dans un lieu
appelé
Jétsémanie
et il dit
aux disciples
asseyez-vous ici
pendant que je me l'enrerai
pour prier
il prit avec lui
Pierre
et les deux fils
des Ébédés
commença à éprouver
la tristesse
et des angoisses
on sait très bien
que Christ
lui-même
n'avait aucun péché
aucune iniquité
mais Esaïe 53
nous dit
que notre coupabilité
les châtiments
de nos transgressions
aient tombé sur lui
les baptêmes du Christ
on sait qu'il était pur
donc il n'avait pas besoin
de se faire baptiser
car les baptêmes
représentaient
d'assumer publiquement
notre saleté spirituelle
notre misère spirituelle
les besoins dans la vache
mais on sait très bien
que Christ
il a assumé
par ses baptêmes
c'était comme
un signé un contrat
ou à partir de là
il allait inaugurer
son ministère public
et qu'il allait
prendre sur ses épaules
la coupabilité
de tous ceux
qu'il représentait
et donc quand on les voit
au Jétsémanie
c'est là où on est
les plus proches
du moment
où il va véritablement
acquitter notre dette
jusque là
pendant toute sa vie
en tant qu'enfant
en tant qu'homme
il a vécu une vie
parfaite
sous la loi
pour pouvoir
nous donner
une obéissance parfaite
devant Dieu
devant les tribunaux
de Dieu
et maintenant la croix
c'est le lieu
de l'exécution
du jugement
de Dieu
et au Jétsémanie
il est en train
de faire comme David
il se voit
devant
les moments
où David
serait
ou était en train
d'être puni
par ses péchés
et même si Dieu
ne pouvait pas
par toutes les souffrances
humaines
faire David
souffrir à la hauteur
de ses péchés
c'était un type
de souffrance
qui veut nous communiquer
rappelez-vous
que si vous êtes traité
selon vos péchés
vous ne pouvez pas
supporter
David était en train
d'arriver à bout
presque à bout
de ses forces
et Jésus
lorsqu'il a pris
non seulement
les péchés de David
mais les péchés
de chaque individu
qu'il a dû payer
à la croix
lorsqu'il a
nous dit
des mots
sans compte
arrivent
plus nombreux
que les cheveux
de ma tête
c'est bien sûr
car Christ
a dû souffrir
à cause
de la transgression
de chacun
de nos péchés
et il a dû
expérimenter
les régés
ou l'abandon
de Dieu
car les péchés
provoquent en Dieu
non seulement
une demande
de justice
punir
à chaque transgression
mais en même temps
ça nous rend
abominables
devant Dieu
impur
réjetable
et à la croix
Christ
il savait
qu'il allait
expérimenter
ces choses
et donc
quand il va
au Gethsémane
c'est pour
qu'il
prenne
les forces
nécessaires
car il était
sous
un pressoir
d'olive
Gethsémane
les lieux
de pressoir
d'olive
pour produire
l'huile
et comme
les processus
de la production
de l'huile
les olives
sont pressées
normalement
trois fois
sous cette
grande pression
des pierres
pour écraser
les petites olives
c'est comme
si Jésus
était accablé
par toutes
les pressions
de tous les péchés
qu'il allait
devoir expérimenter
donc ce qu'il dit
est très similaire
au psaume 40
il dit
mon âme
est triste
jusqu'à la mort
restez ici
éveillé avec moi
puis ayant fait
quelques pas
en avant
il s'est jetté
sur sa face
par terre
et pria ainsi
quelle bataille
anticipée
par la prière
toutes les batailles
les plus difficiles
de nos vies
doivent être jouées
dans la prière
et par cette prière
on voit
que les corps
du Christ
qui a toujours été
en véhicule
très authentique
par rapport
à ses émotions
donc on ne doit pas
toujours prier
à genoux
on ne doit pas
prier toujours
à des bouts
avec une tonalité
de joie
ou de tristesse
on doit permettre!
on
doit permettre que
nos réactions aux
influences de
Dieu au
moment de nos vies soient
authentiques si
nous sommes dans
la joie lorsqu
'on est en train de
parler des
choses glorieuses on
doit répondre avec
un amin une
gloire à Dieu si
nous sommes en
train de prier à
cause d'un sujet des
tristesses
on peut s'agénouiller
si nous sommes
au bout
de nos forces
nous pouvons
être par terre
complètement livrés
au son des dieux
et ici Christ
est au bout
de ses forces
tout comme
avait dit David
dans son psaume
l'évangile
des Luc
Luc
qui était médecin
il va remarquer
quelque chose
que les autres
n'ont pas enregistré
au verset 43
du chapitre 22
il dit alors
un ange de ciel
apparu
pour les fortifier
et étant en agonie
il priait
plus instamment
et sa sueur
des vents
comme des grumeaux
des sangs
qui tombaient à terre
tellement était
son angoisse
au jet de sémonie
qu'il a transpiré
du sang
comme les olives
et dans l'évangile
des gens
c'est qu'il est plus beau
ce qu'il dit
il revend
la troisième fois
et leur dit
dormez maintenant
et reposez-vous
c'est assez
l'heure est venue
voici les fils
de l'homme
sera livré
au monde pécheur
lévez-vous
voici celui
qui met livre
s'approche
et aussitôt
comme il parlait encore
arriva Judas
et l'un des douze
et avec lui
une foule
armée d'épées
et des bâtons
envoyés par les principaux
sacrificateurs
par les escribes
et par les anciens
ces versets
qui nous disent
Jésus dit
c'est assez
allons-y
dans sa crise
dans la légitimité
de sa crise
Jésus
il a souffert
par anticipation
au jet de sémonie
il anticipait
les paiements
de la dette
qui nous concernait
et il a même prié
Dieu
en disant
si possible
éloignez-moi
cette coupe
c'est légitime
pour nous
de prier comme ça
mais ce qu'il cherchait
par la prière
c'était pas
si tant
la délivrance
des circonstances
difficiles
mais surtout
la force
pour en durer
et s'il dit
c'est assez
et certains commentaristes
surtout à la lumière
des breux
chapitre 5
ils sont convaincus
que lorsque Jésus
dit c'est assez
c'est comme s'il disait
j'ai suffisamment prié
j'ai puisé suffisamment
des forces
je peux maintenant
marcher
et endurer
car Dieu
m'a donné
la portion nécessaire
pour supporter
Dieu est mon aide
Dieu sera glorifié
et Dieu sera glorifié
non par la délivrance
de la mort
de la souffrance
ou de la croix
Dieu sera glorifié
par la manière
dont je vais endurer
et il se relève
comme un héros
et c'est pour
Jean va dire
la victoire
sera si glorieuse
que la bataille
cette bataille
en prière
au Géthémanie
cette bataille
qui nous faisons face
aujourd'hui dans nos vies
la manière
dont tu es en train
de se battre
va déterminer
combien glorieuse
sera la victoire
si nous nous battons
comme un héros
ou comme
ceux qui à cause
d'un manque
de fibres émotionnelles
surtout spirituelles
se donnent
comme battus
avant même
d'être frappés
ceux qui sont effrayés
avec ceux qui viennent
à pied
la consolation
de Jérémie
si tu es déjà fatigué
avec ceux qui viennent
à pied
prépare-toi
car
ils arrivent
ceux qui viennent
à cheval
chez vous
si notre force
est petite
est affaiblie
notre foi
est petite
dans les moments
de la détresse
et donc Christ
il a fait la bataille
comme un héros
et il a été victorieux
comment sommes-nous
en train de faire
la bataille aujourd'hui
en hébreu
chapitre 5
verset 7
il nous dit
c'est lui
qui dans les jours
de sa chair
ayant présenté
avec des grands cris
et avec des larmes
et des prières
et des supplications
à celui qui pouvait
les sauver de la mort
il pouvait les sauver
de la mort
il l'a sauvé de la mort
mais à travers la mort
ayant été exaucé
à cause de sa piété
a appris
bien qu'il fût fils
l'obéissance
par les choses
qu'il a souffert
et qui
après avoir été élevé
à la perfection
est devenu
pour tous
ceux qui l'obéissent
l'auteur
dans sa lutte éternelle
vous voyez
un jour
j'étais en train
de traverser
un moment difficile
dans les ministères
Mayra
a passé par
les vallées
des lombes
de la mort
avec un problème
cardiaque
c'était dur
de trouver
de soutien financier
pour continuer
l'oeuvre ici
et j'étais
dans une retraite
avec des pasteurs
où j'attendais
créer des connexions
pour voir
si on pouvait
trouver de support
et j'étais en train
de partager mon histoire
et il y avait
un pasteur
très expérimenté
qui a aussi traversé
beaucoup de difficultés
possiblement
beaucoup plus que nous
mais lui
il a dit quelque chose
qu'à ce moment là
je ne voulais pas
trop entendre
il a dit
tu sais
ces difficultés
qu'on traverse
dans les ministères
c'est pour que
plus tard
et beaucoup plus tard
lorsqu'on racontera
l'histoire
l'histoire sera
plus belle
à entendre
et c'est moi
je me disais
à mon coeur
je ne veux pas
que l'histoire
soit plus belle
je veux
que l'histoire
soit la plus simple
possible
que Dieu soit glorifié
mais nous
on n'a pas les choix
et plus tard
on voit
combien on a gagné
avec tout ça
et donc ici
nous voyons
un Christ
qui non à cause
de ses péchés
chose qu'il n'avait pas
mais à cause
de nos péchés
il a dû vivre
jusqu'au bout
ce qui David
a été épargné
Dieu a délivré
David
il a continué
de vivre
jusqu'à très tard
mais Christ
il a dû traverser
la mort
il a enduré
et c'est par la croix
qu'il a pu
régler
d'une fois pour toutes
cette problématique
David menaçait
des morts
mais Jésus
il a fait face
à la mort
à la sixième heure
à midi
les ténèbres
se sont emparées
pour manifester
les scénarios
d'un jugement cosmique
et Christ
qui disait
mon Dieu
pourquoi m'as-tu
abandonné
et en même temps
comme l'Epsomme
le dit
vient un hâte
à mon secours
mon courage
m'abandonne
au moment même
où tout a été
accompli
Christ va crier
tout est accompli
et ensuite
qu'est-ce qu'il dit
Père
dans tes mains
je te livre
mon esprit
la certitude absolue
qui est la consolation
perpétuelle
et la victoire
déclenchée
de manière irrésistible
pour toujours
cette victoire
qui est venue
à travers la croix
à travers la souffrance
et par là
nous voyons
de manière très claire
que nous pouvons être
dans des moments difficiles
en nous disant
des nombreux mots
m'atteignent
mes péchés sont plus nombreux
que les cheveux de ma tête
veulent me délivrer
au éternel
vient en hâte
à mon secours
que nous nous approchions
du Christ
aujourd'hui
plus fier
à sa miséricorde
qu'à notre innocence
et que nous puissions
nous accrocher
à Christ
et penser
que plus
que désirer
la délivrance
dans un premier moment
nous puissions chercher
non la délivrance
de la croix
mais la délivrance
à travers la croix
et que nous puissions
être sûrs
que nous prions
assez
suffisamment
que nous serons
persévérants
dans la prière
en cherchant Dieu
qui puisse
pourger
nos péchés
totalement
mais avec l'assurance
qu'aucune condamnation
ne reste
car Christ
a déjà pris
toute la souffrance
pour notre condamnation
donc c'est très beau
de nous laisser encourager
par cet homme
qui était un homme comme nous
avide
et qui a commis
des graves péchés
qui a été
beaucoup plus puer
que nous
dans son intégrité
et parfois
encore plus pécheur
que nous
dans les péchés
qu'il a commis
par contre
cette certitude
rendait la possibilité
de la restauration
que Dieu nous donne
la grâce
de rebondir
de nos péchés
avec une grâce
de rendre un témoignage
encore plus glorieux
savoir
recevoir
la correction
des dieux
désirer
avoir les péchés
purifiés
être un modèle
dans l'intégrité
dans l'obéissance
et aussi
dans la répentance
et qu'on puisse
rebondir
comme David
et comme Pierre
qui après
un grave péché
est finalement
devenu
les grands pierres
sous la grâce
de Dieu
bon bien sûr
que nous allons
devoir nous arrêter
ici
on n'aurait pas
le temps
d'avancer davantage
dans les passages!
et donc
que le Seigneur Jésus
soit pour nous
cet espoir certain
là où
les péchés
abondent
la grâce
surabondent
donc
soyons toujours
en train de prier
avec un cœur
qui s'effie
plus à la miséricorde
de Dieu
qu'à notre innocence
amém
levons-nous pour pied